all right Daphne and Shaggy
Daphne and Shaggy uh where you guys from
origin Daphne where are you from
originally Tucson Arizona Tucson and
Shaggy you're from where originally I'm
from Espanola New Mexico yeah Espanola
New Mexico a little small town up north
northern New Mexico
you tell me about your your family
um so my family met my parents actually
met um due to a bank robbery out in uh
in Nashville Colorado my to make a very
long story short my my dad got shot by
his stepdad and on accident okay so CPS
got involved she was 15 years old at the
time and
um they took him away and so they had to
pay a tremendous amount of money to get
him back you know fees and all this
stuff and they wouldn't put up they
wouldn't take the cars that my my uh
then my my grandpa pretty much my step
grandpa had as collateral to get the
loan so meaning they wouldn't take the
loan take that as collateral my grandma
decided to go back to the truck
excuse me go back to the truck you grab
the bandana cowboy hat and a tv7 magnum
and he walked in the bank any other
amount of gunpoint and Robin
so when we robbed them they took off
into Lincoln and they ended up out in
Abington New Mexico which is where my
family actually grew up it's not about
20 miles ish from uh 14 to 20 miles away
from from Espanola and my my mom's dad
had a shop there an auto shop and so my
dad's parents ended up staying there at
auto shop and
um
they
they ended up my mom my dad's mom showed
my mom a picture of her son which is my
dad and my mom you know was the first
child so she got everything she wanted
you know what I mean and she was like I
want him you know and so they uh my my
uh grandma was like okay cool you know
so you can go with them to go and get
him out of you know State custody and
you know all that and um well right
before this happened my grandpa realized
that
my my mom's dad realized that my dad's
stepdad was the bank robber that had
been wanted out from Nashville Colorado
and uh not another it's not like a
glorified at all because you know it's
you snitched but he ended up calling the
cops to save his business you know and
he ended up uh you know getting my my
other my dad's dad you know arrested for
that but
then my mom and my dad's mom they left
to go to the CPS um to CPS in Colorado
and this work is funny actually they uh
went to go and get him back well instead
of paying money to get him back they
went to go visit him and during the
visit they got him in the car and they
got in the back seat and they shoveled a
bunch of clothes on top of him and they
drove right on out with him underneath
all the clothes
so uh that's how my parents met actually
was you know technically from through a
bank robbery and um you know it's uh
it's been a a an interesting life since
then you know how did you describe your
childhood so uh my childhood
um I'll describe it as uh
you know it was good I mean my father
passed away when I was young
um the one that I was telling you about
um But Me growing up I played baseball a
lot I played for China National Little
League and um so I was always an
All-Star team you know I was very good
baseball player
um I was always good in school and stuff
you know we always we always had what we
needed you know uh you know thanks to my
stepdad and my mom you know having
really good jobs and stuff
um but you know there's of course you
know some some traumatic you know
um experience you know like with my my
father you know uh um so um with my
father passing you know there was some
trauma and some uh you know mental
mental you know uh um you know stuff
that went on you know like with uh me
and my my two older brothers I have two
older brothers that were actually um
there with my father when when we had
moved to uh Tucson we moved to Tucson
when I was 18 months old
and um you know they my true older
really stayed with my dad and um last
time I told bro to see my dad was
CPS actually came in and it's because
because my mom had my mom had a dream
that you know that something was
happening you know and that something
about my brothers and you know don't
want to get into it but and they had
called to do welfare check CPS went in
in the middle of the night and they took
my brothers to my dad
so last time my brothers ever seen my
dad was he man cooked on a weight bench
you know and not much longer after that
he passed away due to uh uh sepsis you
had sepsis in his in his arm how old
were you and your dad's past I was uh
three it was uh four days before or my
bad ten days before my fourth birthday
so it was uh you know I don't I remember
too much about him but you know like
I'll have dreams here and there you know
like and uh um you know like I'll I'll
ask anything not so much no more but
when I was younger I'd have dreams and
I'd ask about hey you know did this
happen you know like
um I don't want to get into those dreams
and stuff because some aren't too great
but you know it's just that's that's my
memories of him you know it'd be like
dreams and stuff that I have you know
they're more like flashbacks I guess
um but you know I mean unfortunately the
most memories I have my dad is is you
know it's a tombstone you know what I
mean and
in pictures you know and videos you know
and it sucks but you know
uh you know everybody everybody was
telling you my dad was a great he's a
great dad you know
and you know he you know he loved us you
know and that's what really matters you
know
um so
but uh I I got I got a good life you
know growing up my stepdad being raised
by my stepdad you know he got us into
sports and all that you know and took
very well care of us you know we're
always in the house we always had
everything paid for House of the pool
lake in the backyard you know all that
stuff right
and um so it was it was it was a really
good childhood you know I I would say
you know I was
had good grades I played baseball up
until I was 13 years old and then um I
got into Junior High
um so we moved from Tucson when I was
about
four or five-ish to Chandler Arizona
and then we lived in Chandler for a good
you know eight years ten years or so and
then moved back to Tucson
um due to a some to do with jobs you
know for my parents and uh after that
you know it just uh I won't lie I was I
was 13 and it just it just went downhill
from there I lost my friends you know
and so
um I kind of just got into this
depression you know and and I started
smoking weed and then some weed you know
I mean I'm in Tucson you know so
there's a lot a lot of bad stuff out
there man and um from weed it went to
you know alcohol and alcohol went to
Pills and from pills it went to this and
that you know just so on and so forth
you know
um and it was my parents fault at all
you know they gave us every everything
they could you know so I've never been
on my parents you know it was it was
strictly just my emotions you know and
um
but isn't that much I was was really
great you know it's really really great
Daphne how was yours
mine was pretty good growing up I had
both parents when I was younger
and
um
I was growing up uh I'm just a little
nervous
no I I had my mom she's very loving she
cared about us you know a lot I was
there for us
um was that meals it was that house you
know
um I joined up growing up then my
parents split up
um so that was kind of rough you know it
kind of
it's kind of hard without my dad there
you know he was always in and out in and
out of my sister's life
you know
um
uh sorry how far do you guys go in
school huh how far did you guys go in
school
um I went up to 11th
me I graduated high school with the I
graduated high school uh with the high
school diploma and uh ASC certification
Automotive at andrada Polytechnic High
School how old are you guys I'm 25. I'm
33. okay
you guys met uh where
so
I mean
technically true story is
um I just stick to drugs right when I
was when I was a teenager all right and
um my co-worker was addicted to pills
all right and we went to go get some get
some pills one day and we ended up at
her house due to a friend the first day
a friend of hers that you know was had
some pills for sale so we ended up at
her house and um I'll never forget it to
this day I walk in there and there's
there's there's a uh you know the the
because it was we met over there outside
you know and then we went inside you
know get drinks just like you know you
soda water whatever and stuff and the
kids were there in the little fort and
stuff you know and yeah
all the other stuff had already been
done you know the the drug dealing on
that drug dealer was gone but um we went
inside and um it was it was amazing to
see how she was with her kids you know
like and I'm only 16 at the time and uh
her kids were built they built these
forts out of these couches out of the
couches running couch cushions and stuff
and uh you know I remember you know
seeing her I was like damn she was
beautiful I told the girl that took me
over there Shawna A co-worker of mine I
was like you know I was like she's
gorgeous you know I was like like you
know like whoa and uh I remember you
know we were there for a good 30 minutes
from now or whatever hanging out you
know and then uh after we left I'll
never forget I told Sean I said
her Shannon Sean O'Leary was I was like
Hey I was like I was like
I'm gonna marry that girl one day I told
her she laughs at me she's like yeah
right she's like she's been with her
baby daddy for so long she's like you're
you'll never know not gonna happen you
know right I was like all right mark my
words I said I'm gonna marry that girl
one day I promise you I want to marry
that girl one day and uh I went to
prison at uh 19 years old and I got out
at
20 right before turning 21 I got out I
got on 420 2018 and
um so when I got out though I ended up
going to a metronome Clinic because I
unfortunately had overdose right after I
got out on on May 1st which not the
first time I've overdosed on May 1st
which is actually
um the the name the day my father passed
away May 1st and um I overdosed and well
when I I decided to go back to the
methadone clinic and I was in a group I
was in a relapse relapse prevention
group and um I I met her I'd seen her
there and you know we just you know
talked and stuff and
that I was stoned out of my mind right
and she was like yeah she's like I love
it you know and I was like yeah you know
you smoke whatever whatever we started
smoking afterwards you know and um after
that
I remember talking to her one day a
couple days after I said oh my God I
know where I know you from and she's
like where and I said I came to your
house one day I said and your girls had
a fort built in the thing I should walk
into the house I said right there to the
left there was couches and the girls had
four built and then there was a tail
right there and she's just like look at
me like I'm [ __ ] psychotic she's like
who the [ __ ] are you you know what I
mean and I was like and I was like and
you know what I was like I told the girl
that brought me there that I was gonna
marry you one day you know and she's got
even more like you know you know cheeks
turn right she's blushing and stuff you
know like but you know like At first she
was kind of like what the [ __ ] is this
dude you know but and uh um you know it
was it was it was just cool to
to realize you know like sometimes life
does play out that way you know like I I
wasn't joking when I said that back then
you know I was gonna marry that girl
went down I truly honestly wanted to be
with her I [ __ ] loved her you know
like I didn't even know her and I loved
her you know and uh what's even crazier
is in prison I just had these dreams
about
about this girl that dark hair you know
I never see her face I never see her
face in prison never when I was in my
dream never see your face
and when I got out and I met her again I
finally realized I was like oh my God
that's that's why that's who it is you
know I knew who it was but subconscious
of my mind wouldn't let me see your face
you know
and uh so anyways we met we met at a
methadone clinic um
officially you know I guess you would
say we officially met a methadone clinic
and we hit it off from there was a
little sober we're both clean we stole
her we stole our ex's truck
her baby daddy's truck uh we went up to
Mount Lemon up in in New Mexico in
Tucson
um and we went camping and one of the
funniest things about that that that
time was going up to Mount Lemmon we're
halfway at the mountain and there's no
cell phone service at all at all at all
okay
and she kind of I'm driving she kind of
goes like this to the door so bad on my
part moves over the door and stuff out
of my butt it grabs a handle a little
bit you know she's like
um
you know she's like um Matt I'm like
what she's like
what'd you go to prison for
I'm like a little late so listening to
you know you know whatever told her what
it was you know outside it's listening
to it's listening
it's listening to transport and narcotic
drug for sale is what it was all right
so basically I was I was a middleman in
the drug deal okay and he got it got me
two years you know and um it was just so
funny because she was like are you sure
you know and I was like look I like will
you turn right back down the mountain
right now I'll go back down the mountain
and I'll I'll pull up my stuff you know
right now it's a whole way up around I'm
trying to pull him up and pull up my
stuff pull my stuff finally pulls up
like see you know calm me down a lot you
know and uh you know ever since then man
it's just it's been great man like we
you know
we were we're we're clean as long as I
ever been cleaners with her four years
you know four years we were sober how
did you guys relapse I crashed the
motorcycle
I crashed my brothers My Brothers Harley
Davidson and um
I went to my neighbor's house for some
ibuprofen he didn't have any ibuprofen
and he had
uh fentanyl blues and um and I
I was in so much pain man like I mean
I'm talking I'd I took off on this bike
man like I wrote crotch rockets you know
when I was younger I wrote a crotch
rocket and stuff so get on a Harley when
you never go to Harley it's completely
different completely [ __ ] different
anybody says anything different is a
liar they never wrote one because it's
you lean you lean with it with that that
that that Crossroad you know what I mean
like and this one was not like that the
amount of
torque it has an amount of just balls it
has it's just amazing you know like and
it was it was a screaming eagle it was a
Harley Davidson Screaming Eagle so it
wasn't no small bike you know it was a
big bike and um well anyway so that
being said what happened was I went I
was in the casino parking lot and made a
very long story showing how to crash a
bike was that I I went first to second
to Third and when I went to third for
some reason my mind still tell me I'm
only a second you know I rode a bike in
a couple years and so I downshifted well
when I downshifted I thought I
downshifted twice to go back down the
first right well my downshifted line
down shut down a second
so I'm coming up on the curb you know I
barely I I got like this close to the
curb literally like that goes to scream
as I'm turning right and like all right
come on I made it you know I made it
hell yeah I dumped the clutch so that
clutch out I'm in second gear
and the back tire just said
right on your right from underneath me
man so boom I flew off boom look at him
he hit the day I hit the bike I rolled I
tumbled and road rash everywhere I
freaking I bruised and fraction freaking
all kinds of [ __ ] you know and it was
just it was horrible man it was really
painful and so um
she was she was there she watched it
happen and everything my brothers my
brother was there my brother ran up
my bike he's like and he's like oh my
God little brother are you okay you know
like he it to me honestly I was
surprised he came up to me first before
the bike you know I thought he's gonna
go to the bike first but he generally
gave a [ __ ] about me you know and if I
was okay you know and after he found out
I was okay he was like all right cool
[ __ ] you dude you know what I mean like
now he makes his bike's okay you know
like but uh um yeah the motorcycle
accident did it for me and then um I
think just just me me having
having done it done them and then her
finding out and catching me with them
and seeing seeing them you know they
were robotics you know and I mean that's
what happens man is rheumatic and you
you you see that it ends up I'm sorry
I'm getting I don't know you got the
painkillers you you got on pain killers
yeah no I didn't no I didn't get on
painkillers I didn't go to the doctor
I cleaned up all myself and I went to my
neighbor's house to get some some
ibuprofen he didn't have a girlfriend he
only had some some perk 30s
gaming me man and it just went down over
there man people started doing them and
it was time to stop since man this is
about a year ago so it wasn't too long
ago I was never addicted to pills I was
I was already addicted to heroin heroin
and and mess actually and um I got I got
back on I got on these these these the
new the new thing the blues you know the
fentanyl you know the fentanyl the the
fake 30s with their their m30s they're
they're fentanyl oxycontins you know
oxycodones
saying you know fake whatever you want
to call them fake fennel 30s and um you
know it just it just got bad from there
man the pain was was so unbearable man
it was just like honestly I would rather
have a fracture or a break than bruise
any day any day the bruise the bruised
ribs were so freaking horrible man like
I couldn't I could not believe it you
know and then
my shoulder
I ran over when I was 16. but my by my
by my girlfriend at the time and uh so I
got ran over and I broke my shoulder had
an evulsion fracture on my shoulder and
my shoulder this day is still messed up
you can see it in a shirt it's it's just
it's it just hangs you know what I mean
like so uh um it's it's pretty bad man
that pain is always there and so that
added on to the motorcycle accident you
know it's just two two and barrels man
and so I started doing that and then I
got to where I was getting sick from it
again and I just we know we're both
doing them man and didn't stop you know
and it's been down from there I mean
well I'm gonna sit downhill because I I
ended up opening up my own business you
know after that
um I own I own I still own it I still
own it's called the knights armor Auto
Recycling
um I'm an Auto Recycler so I basically I
buy a car and I take all the core Parts
off of it I sell all the core parts or I
stack up the core parts and then I sell
all the core parts and I strapped the
vehicle
so tell me about this lifestyle you're
on drugs for how many years now
as of right now we're all together oh
back and forth It's been you've had
breaks but you've had how many years on
again honestly man we've only been on
drugs again for about a year
and it's been by my worst my worst
relapse ever you guys are in La why it
was actually so I relapsed in Tucson and
then uh um and it ended up happening was
I don't know how uh allegedly I was uh
um allegedly I was selling some some
stuff that I wasn't you know and I made
a bunch of money but the money was
through my business okay so they tried
to say I was selling this stuff which I
wasn't and you know it ended up being
they ended up being to where I had all
this money and they were trying to say
that I was money laundering and all this
when I I really wasn't there I got I got
I got receipts for all my stuff all my
my uh uh my my uh my profit my
in a nutshell why did you come to L.A
really um the detox bro I came here for
detox I just gave me what detox I came
and uh we just got out of detox we say
this really really nice place called Lux
recovery but very nice place couldn't do
it I couldn't do it man it was just it's
too much got no stuff right is it did
the man dude
anybody out there that's that's on on
Fentanyl
I strongly strongly urge you to to
really think about what you're doing man
and if you've barely been on it please
just stop man try to get off do whatever
you can to get off man because this is
the worst withdrawal of your life I've
withdrawn off heroin I was on alcohol I
was off crack
methamphetamine all of the above
barbiturates benzo you know all of it
and Fentanyl is is horrible watching
watching watching my wife go through
what she had to go through
it was heartbreaking you know we both
ended up in the hospital and um
you know we were almost through it and
they they were giving us you know
medication I'm not gonna say they
weren't because they were they were
trying to take care of us okay
but
it's so bad medication wasn't working
there you're in a suboxone you know it
just did not work man it did not work
for us and it I had to get out of there
we had to leave you know and um
unfortunately we left and we had we had
to come out and we had to you know
get get right again you know and so now
what we're trying to do is we're we're
going to go back home Tucson and we're
gonna we're gonna go get back on what
we're on we met which is methadone
because that's something that we know
works you know
um and I'm not I'm not I'm not
encouraging anybody to do this at all
because methadone is horrible okay so
don't
don't ever think that I'm encouraging
anybody to get on methadone unless you
know it works for you because it is not
the way to go man methadone stays in
your bones and it is honestly a worse
kicked in fentanyl too but me and me and
my wife were on Metro Maintenance for
four years and we did not judge drugs
once until I crash my brother's
motorcycle
and um like I said the only reason that
was was because I needed ibuprofen and
my neighbor didn't have it and I didn't
have it and uh you know it sucks to say
it but you know
the devil's always going to be there
that was always going to be there and
he's always going to try to get you to
do this you should do this right and you
can ask her there's many many many many
many times I'm talking dozens if not
hundreds of times but then people would
be like hey you want to smoke this blue
you know try this blue you know let's
smoke this blue and I'll just turn them
down turn them down turn them down turn
them down right here's that pain man it
was that pain that pain of of of being
in so much pain from the motorcycle
accident and then
finally just the honestly emotional too
because I just wrecked my brother's
[ __ ] 2013 Harley Davidson Screaming
Eagle you know so that is emotional pain
to that too so I felt depressed you know
all this
and you know I just I I I I did it you
know but uh um it's it's it affects your
life a lot man and it's
it's not it's not worth it man it's
really not worth it definitely you have
kids right
yes I do how old are your kids
I have six all together and 16
and I have twins
that are 11 now 11 and 10 I believe
oh eleven eleven and nine what years was
it born again
um two thousand who's raising all your
kids they're with their dad yeah they're
um the twins are with their dad uh my
oldest is with her dad and then we have
a uh four year old my daughter my
daughter's with uh um with my sisters uh
this is her this is her hand and her uh
her hands and her footprints
when she was first born
she was a uh you know it's crazy about
that actually no I just look at it again
is it so remember I said my dad died 10
days before my fourth birthday
well my daughter was born
10 days after my birthday
so it just kind of you know and and my
my daughter's named after my mom my dad
my brother and my mom my dad and both my
brothers and her grandma so Ray and Ray
is my mom's middle name Lynn is my dad's
middle name Ray is also my brother my
brother Lucas's middle name and Lynn is
my brother Jesse's real name so it's Ray
Ray Lynn and then Lois which is her
grandma and night so what would you guys
say is your biggest fear my biggest fear
honestly man
my biggest fear is losing my mom or my
daughter
my mom's got cancer
and you know it's just
for me being losing my my kids all
together
it's a rough lifestyle
not in the strongest situation to
be the support you need to be for your
kids or your families yeah we just lost
my uncle too my uncle just drowned
so I'm sorry
sorry man I mean my best friend ran then
what got me to stop doing drugs is my
best friend his name is Jacob bonius and
uh rest in peace of love you love the
Dirty Dancing literally like my brother
and uh
last thing is this man never told me
when I got out over those things I
overdose on May 1st
2018 and um last thing that a man ever
told me was Matt he said life's not
about getting [ __ ] up
and who can do you know the [ __ ] the
biggest shot of dope who can drink the
most [ __ ] you know with you General
shots you can you know
chewing down the beer ball in the
fastest you know all that that's not
what life's about he tells me and this
goes for everybody I want everybody to
know this for real
life
this goes to my my best friend
jacobonius he told me that life
is about
having a family
and making sure that your family has
everything that they want and need
and taking care of them
and when he told me that it hit me hit
me hard
and I lived by that
he died from drug overdose
let's see remember
he's so May June July August September
October he died from a drug overdose six
months later
after he told me this
he was he was uh throwing Coke and uh
from from what we all understand is that
the Coca-Cola fentanyl which
ended all these now you know all the
drugs all the drugs are caught with
fentanyl guys every single drug out
there has fentanyl Believe It or Not
meth has fentanyl cocaine has retinol
crackheads Fentanyl heroin has been
everything I spent on it because they
want you to be addicted to it okay
so I don't know if they just have the
cut right or what but you had sorted
some coke and uh I'm gonna take a shower
started some coke
and uh his baby mama found him on the
ground hours so later blue bloody nose
you know and uh
it's just it was down down was hard for
me that was really hard for me I don't
think she'll even ever read that one I I
got told that and I just I lost it I
screamed I freaking lost it lost
and it just and I couldn't take it it's
my brother you know what I mean like
literally like
and so that was hard and uh I don't want
anybody to ever have to go through that
you know like to go through what I had
to go through
like it's literally like losing losing a
brother man and and what's so [ __ ] up
about it is that
you know I mean I started doing those
those two drugs together you know
and so it was really hard man really
hard
what's your biggest regret Daphne
your biggest regret
everybody's regret
would be
relapsing
and not seeing my children before I left
Tucson
your plan is to go back there though
yeah yeah
because every time when I leave town I
always be there like I always see him
you know before I leave town and this
last time when I left I didn't see him I
think I can help you I really regret
that
what would you say is the most important
lesson you guys have learned
um
don't take family for granted
you know what I mean honestly don't take
my eye for granted and uh
live every day like it's your last or
like you know and then
man dude take every conversation you
have with somebody like it's your last
if you ever have it because you know
what it may be the reason I say that is
because
my uncle sold my dad's truck the last
truck of my that we had on my dad's
and um
man my uncle died you know we just died
and be drowned right and
the last thing I told my uncle was that
I [ __ ] hate you Jeff and I hope you
die in miserable [ __ ] death
I told him that
all right I hate you I never want to see
you again I hope you die miserable
[ __ ] death
and we use firefighter and one of his
worst fears you know that I know of was
you know
Burning live or drowning
and if anybody knows anything about
drowning if any of you guys know
anything about drowning that is probably
one of the most miserable deaths there
is
because with with Bernie alive
you
pass out
you know we're drowning my understanding
of it and everybody else is that I know
of there's seven stages of drowning and
I'm not positive but I'm pretty sure
you're
um uh conscious for at least five of
them maybe even more
but it's it's miserable you know and and
I feel like a piece of [ __ ] because I
told my dad I told my uncle that
I hate him and I hope he dies invisible
[ __ ] death
and he did
and he eats me every single day and I
just miss his funeral too
[Music]
Matt thank you so much for sharing your
stories
try to help you guys get back to Tucson
thank you I appreciate you uh listening
to our stories thank you man good luck
with everything thank you God bless